allez euh les chéris on va passer au
invités du soir on va revenir sur
Sébastien cé sur cé on en a parlé hier
une plainte pour de c'est une plainte
des plaintes pourquoi qui ont été déposé
alors il y a une plainte pour viol qui a
été déposée et l'actualité judiciaire
d'aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a
l'ouverture d'une enquête préliminaire
voilà nous raconter tout ça desit des
faits que koe conteste fermement et on a
de nouveaux éléments encore Gill on va
vooir tout ça et on a de nouveaux
éléments exclusifs sur cette affaire
aujourd'hui donc c'est énergie puisqu'on
rappelle que Sébastien C tous les jours
surénergie de de 15h à 20h je crois et
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui il n'était
pas l'antaine cé c'est Energie qui a
décidé de communiquer sur cette affaire
le groupe a annoncé le retrait
provisoire de l'animateur de leurs
antennes regardez merci
toutard depuis plusieurs jours
l'animateur coé fait l'objet de lourdes
accusations des SMS extrêmement Salas
sont dévoilés et alors que l'homme de
radio présente chaque jour son émission
sé sur Energie depuis 201 10 on est
surnergie l'animateur qui est désormais
visé par une enquête pour viol sur
mineur de plus de 15 ans et viol et qui
affirme être innocent a été écarté de
l'antenne après un accord avec la
station je ne prendrai pas l'antenne
aujourd'hui je suis éprouvé par les
accusations qui sont portées contre moi
ouverture d'une enquête préliminaire
retrait de énergie témoignage de la
plignante nouvelle révélation sur
l'affire
cé s'il vous plaît on se calme s'il vous
plaît merci
donc Gill Verdez
énergie a suspendu l'émission ou bien
c'est cé c'est c'est ils se sont mis
dans un commeun
accord le commeun accord c'est je dirais
politique et médiatique en fait ennergie
a jugé que c'était très compliqué que
Sébastien cohet reste à l'antenne et
puis Sébastien cohet lui-même qui est
fatigué épuisé s'est dit bon bah
finalement c'est une bonne décision
voilà est-ce que vous pensez que ils ils
ont bien fait de de pas de pas être à
l'antenne aujourd'hui que ce soit cohé
ou énergie moi je moi je moi je pense
que vous pensez que non non parce que
c'est une manière de le condamner
méditiquement alors que il faut laisser
encore une fois la justice faire son
travail et je trouve que en ne le
mettant pas à à l'antenne il le désavoue
on veille ou non et ça va mettre encore
accentuer encore cette cette cette
plainte alors que pour moi ça doit
rester dans une sphère juridique et pas
médiatique et je pense ou ou alors
justement le communiqué d'énergie ils
ont publié un communiqué de presse ils
annoncent le retrait provisoire donc de
de de Sébastien cette décision
temporaire prise d'un commun accord avec
Sébastien cohé est guidé par la
nécessité de garantir la sérénité qui
doit prévaloir face à des démarches
judiciaires portant sur des accusations
graves à l'encontre de Sébastien
animateur de l'émission see produite par
sa société Bioware production qui les
conteste publiquement l'autorité
judiciaire étant saisie il lui
appartient à elle seule de conduire les
investigations dans le respect des
droits des personnes et de la
présomption d'innocence si aucun fait
contraire de la Charte à la charte
éthique du groupe ou à attentatoire la
dignité n'avait été signalée le groupe
nnergie a cependant dès le 17 novembre
2023 ordonné une enquête interne cette
enquête toujours en cours et conduite
par un cabinet extérieur et totalement
indépendant pour moi il y a quand même
deux poids de mesure entre on a vu que
M6 euh soutener son animateur cabinet
externe si c'est un cabinet interne
d'ailleurs il y a des il y a des des
plaignants qui n'ont pas été retenus
dans l'enquête interne donc M6 donc M6
M6 qu'il faut savoir c'est que M6 a
vraiment vraiment vraiment soutenu son
animateur à fond et ennergie G c'estê
c'est moins c'est moins net moi moi ce
que j'aime dans le communiqué que je
trouve bien structuré c'est le trème mot
3è ligne sérénité c'estàdire que s'il
vient s'il vient à l'antenne s'il reste
à l'antenne dans une émission comme ça
de libre antenne je trouve que la
sérénité même pour lui n'est pas
garantie donc je trouve que c'est une
bonne décision et ce qui est intéressant
aussi Cyril c'est que Energie a
déclenché l'enquête dès le 17 novembre
qu'ils sont partis avant c'est-à-dire
que Energy a envie de savoir
effectivement ce qui s'est passé et ça
je trouve que c'est intéressant de leur
part voilà alors après on peut dire il
lâche Sébastien cohet mais lui
franchement moi j'avais échangé hier
avec son entourage il est combatif ça va
lui permettre aussi de se consacrer à ce
lourd dossier pour se défendre voilà
donc là il est il est aventure on va on
a des nouveaux éléments dans un instant
juste là-dessus Myriam palongba les
éléments les pardon les les les éléments
bah les éléments c'est que vous en avez
dit une bonne partie hein c'est que donc
il y a cette enquête préliminaire qui
vient d'être déclenchée par le parquet
de bouranbreste qui va donc suivre des
il y a des investigations qui vont
suivre sous la responsabilité du
procureur de la République évidemment la
plaignante va être à nouveau entendu Coe
va également également être entendu et
il y a certainement je vraon d'abord sur
énergie sur énergie sur énergie vous
voulez savoir quoi sur énergie bah donc
voilà donc là pour l'instant c'est
combien de temps ça va durer combien de
temps bah c'est jusqu'à c'est jusqu'à
jusqu'à nouvelle ordre parce que pour
l'instant il y a pas de il y a pas de il
y a pas de dat ce est d'ailleurs très
compliqué pour énergie parce que
l'émission de cohé rapporte énormément à
la radio c'est plus d'un quart des
recettes publicitaires on parle de
millions d'euros dans dans ce cas-là
donc c'est très très très embêtant mais
en même temps il rapporterait 65
millions d'euros en recette publicitaire
par an coé sur énergie c'est ce qu'on
m'a dit bah j'avais moins en net mais
moi j'avais 20 millions net ah ouais bah
ouais mais moi je je suis tunisien non
non mais je vous fais confiance non non
non voilà non non mais ça doit être ça
doit être le truc c'est qu'en plus à
énergie visiblement il y a des il y a
quand même pas mal de témoignages aussi
qui sont remontés en interne il y a pas
mal de choses qui se sont dites en
interne et c'est aussi pour cette raison
que l'enquête interne a été déclenchée
avant même que le dépôt de plainte a été
fait et que du coup ils ont décidé d'un
commun accord de le suspendre de de
l'antenne oui très bien il aucune
plainte en interne précisonsle a des
investigations il y a aucune plainte en
inter Sébastien cé a tweté également je
ne prendrai pas l'antenne aujourd'hui en
acccord avec Energie je suis éprouvé par
les accusations non seulement
ignomineieuses mais surtout mensongères
qui sont portées contre moi j'ai les
preuves de mon innocence mes avocats
vont saisir le parquet de nanire je me
battrai contre cette lamentable
entreprise de déstabilisation prenez
soin de vous je vous aime fort oui c'est
ça l'émission a a rapporté 47 millions
d'euros de rette publicité entre
septembre et octobre 2023 voilà donc
donc c'est vos chiffres c'est c'est mes
chiffres exactement j'étais j'étais
j'étais j'étais mieux placé sur les
chiffres mais c'est souvent le cas euh
non mais c'est c'est vrai euh alors on
va revenir euh sur cette affaire et sur
les messages diffusés sur les réseaux
sociaux euh myiam et et et Gilles donc
c'est ça qui a mis le feu au poudre et
on va revenir sur le témoignage euh de
cette de cette jeune fille euh voilà qui
a témoigné hier sur BFM TV ave elle
était on là on la voyait pas hein on va
voir ça dans un instant sur les les
messages diffusés sur les réseaux
sociaux euh euh Myriam et Gill oui il y
a eu énormément de de de de messages
depuis depuis le 13 octobre où l'affaire
a été révélée sur sur les réseaux
sociaux d'ailleurs d'abord la la la la
plaignante mais même tout un tas de de
de jeunes femmes he une certaine
Mathilde qui a parlé longuement sur les
réseaux sociaux il y en a plein d'autres
et tous ces témoignages vont être
évidemment apportés à la plainte et il
se dit même que d'autres plaintes
pourraient être déposées par la suite
alors pas forcément par des jeunes
filles mineurs mais que des plaintes
devraient suivre en plus de celles qui
ont déjà été déposées euh sur les sur
les les les les échanges avec cette
jeune fille non il y a une chose qui
pose question sur les échanges sans
voilà alors justement on les a les
échanges on peut ils ont été révélés
partout après on sait pas s'il y a des
trucs qui ont été effacés pas effac en
fait ce qui pose question c'est les
horaires c'est que parlerait tout seul
pendant 2 3 heures et se répondrait à
lui-même appation avec laquelle sont
envoyé ses messages c'est WhatsApp et on
sait qu'on peut supprimer des messages
donc là c'est vrai qu'on a l'impression
regarder entre 18h25 et 22h que Koé
parle seul ça peut poser question sur
l'éventualité que certains messages
auraient été supprimés dans cette conv
vraim toi toi qui tu as travaillé en
plus avec non ouais moi je pense que
comme Guillaume je pense qu' làdedans il
y a des messages qui qui ont été effacés
alors j'espère qu'il a tous les messages
j'espère que il va il va dire comme il a
dit qu'il va qu' va prouver qu'il est
qu'il est innocent dans cette histoire
et que c'est une entreprise de
déstabilisation parce que ça me paraît
ça me paraît quand même curieux et mais
mais s'il a fait des choses mal il
faudra qu'il soit puni mais moi jeis
comme Guillaume je dis que là il manque
quand même beaucoup je vois pas je vois
pas moi moi je le connais cé c'est un
ami je le connais je le vois pas parler
de 19h30 à 22h tout seul comme ça
envoyer des à bombarder si ça répond pas
ça répond pas ça me paraît ça me paraît
bizarre et sur des extraits que j'ai vu
sur sur BFM j'ai aussi d'autres extraits
sur Youtube ou a dit
a dit contraire justement vous allez
nous en parler parce que vous allez nous
en parler on va voir les extraits vous
allez nous dire Raymond ce qui vous
dérange que hier elle était pour la
première fois la télé là la plignante
elle a raconté comment aurait eu
lieu le premier contact avec ko qu'elle
dénonce
regardez je suis montée dans sa chambre
et il me dit bah écoute fais-moi s
fais-moi écouter ta maquette radio il y
a pas de problème donc il s'est mis à
côté de moi et c'est à ce momentl en
fait où il a où il a baissé son pantalon
de vraiment quelques centimètres
absolument presque ici quoi il a
absolument tout sorti et c'est là c'est
à ce moment-là qu'il m'a dit c'est comme
ça qu'on réussi dans la radio il faut
que tu le fasses je l'ai regardé droit
dans les yeux et je lui ai
dit je peux pas et il m'a dit si tu veux
réussir dans la radio il faut le faire
donc moi 15 ans bah c'est ce que j'ai
exécuté ça
elle a continué à m'appeler et c'est ce
qui m'a sauvé parce que il s'est il a
arrêté et il m'a dit écoute ta sœur elle
va finir par monter on descend on va
voir d'autres extraits dans dans un
instant oui alors ce qui ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'il y a une vraie
offensive de la part de la plignante
médiatique c'estàdire qu'elle est
d'abord sur les réseaux elle estime
qu'elle n'est pas entendue ensuite elle
porte plainte et là elle apparaît et de
la vie de l'entourage de Sébastien cohet
ça va alimenter le fait que pour eux ce
soit une entreprise de déstabilisation
parce que ça va très vite mais attention
il faut respecter la parole de la
plignante et nous ne pouvons pas prendre
partie du tout hein voilà aujourd'hui en
tout cas la plignante elle est apaisée
he le fait d'avoir d'avoir parlé de et
et de de d'avoir dit ce qu'elle avait à
dire c'était quelque chose qu'elle
gardait en elle depuis pas mal d'années
elle se sent beaucoup mieux d'autant
plus qu'il y a d'autres témoignages qui
viennent de corroborer son expérience
absolument et C oui un autre élément qui
est pointé par ceux qui défendent cé
c'est que cette plignante était donc une
fan de coé de ses émissions et qu'elle
aurait encore une fois ça justifie rien
du tout mais qu'elle aurait continué à
poster des photos avec lui en compagnie
de Cé sur sa photo de profil avec lui
donc ceux qui défendent ce disent mais
regardez elle était toujours en bon
terme avec puelle l'ffiché sur sa photo
de profil après présum mais l'emprise tu
sais ça existe alors elle explique que
depuis sa vie est un calv1 elle a
d'ailleurs fait elle a dit plusieurs
tentatives de suicide regardez
j'ai essayé de mettre fin à mes jours
que ma sœur elle portait elle portait s
ses accusations depuis depuis les faits
et je je fait passer pour une menteuse
et j'ai en fait j'ai détruit ma famille
ou je dirais plus qu'il a détruit ma
famille j'ai conscience de la
présomption d'innocent j'ai conscience
que les gens peuvent croire ce qu'ils
veulent moi je veux juste être libéré de
ce poids de d'avoir presque détruit ma
famille d'avoir presque détruit ma vie
parce queaujourd'hui j'ai 25 ans donc
c'était c'était il y a 1 an et il y a 10
ans je me dis que pendant tout ce temps
je me suis détruite et et je me suis
empêché de vivre rement ma vie c'est
horrible c'est terrible ouais bon le
témoignage est évidemment très fort on
va pas le le minimiser après une des des
interrogations de l'entourage de de
Sébastien cohet c'est sur l'âge alors
c'est ça alors Miriam et Miriam alors
sur l'âge c'est c'est un peu compliqué
parce que effectivement quand elle a
connu cé elle avait 15 ans c'était donc
pendant ce fameux rendez-vous à
Disneyland et quand elle a été à Genève
elle avait visiblement 16 ans puisque
elle est née en septembre et que du coup
voilà a des espèces d'incohérence dans
son témoignage où un coup elle dit
qu'elle avait 15 ans un coup elle dit
qu'elle avait 16 ans et c'est quand même
assez important notamment pour la peine
encouru à ce moment-là pour viol ou
c'est très important même parce que bien
évidemment l'enquête va déterminer la
cohérence ou l'incohérence des
témoignages et s'il y a des incohérences
sur l'âge effectivement ça peut après
fragiliser exactement un témoignage
d'autant que on le disait ensuite il y a
per de si je puis dire la la relation ou
en tout cas la publication de photos le
fait que cet été la plignante souhaitait
d'après l'entourage de Sébastien c le
rejoindre donc est-ce qu'il y a une
obsession pour lui c'est ce que en tout
cas va plaider l'entourage de Sébastien
c que cette jeune femme en fait n'a
cessé de vouloir être proche de lui
voilà elle dit qu'elle a dû être
hospitalisée et ce traitement
antidépresseur depuis plusieurs années
sur l'âge
pardon depuis tout ça je suis suivi déjà
par psychiatre une psychologue et qui
m'aide énormément j'ai été hospitalisé à
plusieurs reprises je suis sous
traitement sous antidépresseur sous
traitement pour dormir la nuit c'est des
cauchemars que je fais et que et que je
continue à faire à l'heure actuelle donc
maintenant j'attends juste de pouvoir
m'en sortir pour pouvoir prendre ces
traitements parce qu'avec ces
traitements en fait on sent plus rien on
fait plus rien et on sent complètement
vide alors je me dis que justement c'est
peut-être la seule chose aussi qui m m'a
poussé à porter la plainte parce que
j'avais peur et pendant ce temps-là j'ai
réussi à pouvoir faire les choses Raymon
vous disz poignant c'est poignant comme
témoignage parce que là la la nana là
moi moi je la crois à 200 % sauf que moi
j'ai eu des textos j'ai eu des messages
j'ai eu des dates qui collent pas du
tout notamment où elle a 18 ans quand
elle est sur une émission sur Fun Radio
quand je vois ça je me dis c'est c'est
poignant c'est c'est fort ce qu' ce qui
arrivé à cette n mais d'un autre côté
quand je reçois les textos et les
preuves qu'on me dit regarde c'est une
mytho c'est une mytho j'ai pas
l'impression que c'est la même personne
j'ai pas l'impression qu'on parle de la
même personne parliez vous parliez
instant de trucs sur Facebook de post
sur Facebook et de et et de témoignages
vous dites pour vous il y a il y a des
dates qui collent pas où elle passe dans
une émission de radio sur Fun Radio chez
ano et et Marion où elle dit qu'elle a
18 ans donc ça colle pas du tout avec
les les dates qu'on me dit là mais mais
quand je vois ça je je vois le
témoignage je me dis c'est si c'est
passer un truc et en même temps j'ai
j'ai j'ai du mal par rapport à ce qu'on
me dit alors ils réservent leur leur
défense à la police et j'espère que ça
va aller très vite alors justement on va
avoir des infos dans un instant avec de
ce qui se passe actuellement je voulais
juste préciser que sur l'âge le parquet
a ouvert une information judiciaire une
enquête préliminaire pardon oui pour
viol sur enfants de plus de 15 Ansur 15
donc ça veut dire que eux ils retiennent
un âge au-delà de 15 ans entre 15 et 18
ans il y a deux deux plainte une pour
mineur de plus de 15 ans et pour viol
sur le fait queelle avait peut-être
moins de 16 ans ou 15 ans donc j'ai Enie
te dire même là je m'en fous c'est le
viol je veux même pas qu'il est viol en
fait là je m'en fous qu'elle est 17 ans
ou qu'elle est 20 ans c'est le viol
c'est l'appellation viol mais j'espère
que ça va vite sortir vérité V sortir
parce que je le vois pas je le vois pas
je le vois pas violer en fait donc là je
limite je m'en fous c'est le viol moi
qui m'intéresse j'ai l'un des bookur
l'un des bookurs de ce fameux épisode à
Genève qui m'a effectivement confirmé la
présence de cette jeune femme et qui m'a
quand même aussi confirmé la prés le
fait que avait fait mon monter dans sa
chambre d'hôtel après il a pas pu me
décrire ce qui s'était passé dans la
chambre d'hôtel puisquil n'y était pas
mais mais en tout cas il m'a confirmé
cet événement alors elle raconte qu'elle
veut juste qu'il paye pour ce qu'il a
fait ce qu'elle a dit dans le témoignage
hier oui et d'ailleurs on va
regarder peu importe ce qui se passe peu
importe ce qui qui se dit peu importe ce
qui qui fait quoi je veux juste être
reconnu en tant que tel et que lui il
passe il paye pour ce qu'il a fait qu'il
arrête d' faire B de victimes c'est tout
ce que je demande
oui d'ailleurs pour revenir sur
l'enquête préliminaire parce que c'est
très intéressant c'est il faut peut-être
juste rappeler ce qu'il a une enquête
préliminaire une enquête préliminaire ça
veut dire que on va enquêter pour voir
s'il y a ou non une infraction hein on
en est au stade où tout le monde va être
entendu pour déterminer s'il y a des
indices qui établissent l'existence
d'une infraction pénale et effectivement
cette enquête elle est ouverte pour viol
sur mineur de plus de 15 ans et viol
parce que la plainte porte donc sur de
viols le viol au moment à Genève donc au
moment où cette jeune femme était
mineure et un viol en 2022 donc voilà il
y a beaucoup d'écarts entre les de
d'écart entre les deux viol 8 ans il y a
oui un peu moins mais voilà ça c'est
intéressant c'est il y a il y a de viols
et c'est ouvert à Bour eness parce que
la jeune femme a porté plainte dans l'un
où elle réside voilà au niveau
judiciaire où on en est c'est le début
de l'action judiciaire puis après il va
y avoir aussi des expertises
psychologiques de la jeune femme é va
être entendu il va pouvoir aussi
apporter ses preuvesin il y a plein de
choses qui vont être déterminantes
pendant l'enquête ils pourront
éventuellement être confrontés aussi et
effectivement il y aura certainement une
confrontation alors justement la défense
elle en est où g la défense de Sébastien
cohé c'est de dire que c'est une
machination c'est de dire que c'est une
déstabilisation c'est de dire
globalement alors et disIl nous le
prouverons qu'il n'y a rien alors
effectivement là où on ne peut pas
répondre et Raymon les évoquait c'est
sur le contenu la réalité l'existence de
ces SMS moi j'ai pas l'info et ça
l'entourage de Sébastien C et lui-même
le réserve pour la police pour les
enquêteurs mais sur le fond ils disent
qu'il n'y a rien c'est que Sébastien
cohet ne dévie pas de sa ligne qui est
de dire il n'y a pas eu de viol et je le
prouverai voilà donc on a deux versions
qui sont extrêmement contradictoires
c'est souvent le cas dans ce type
d'affaire et ce sera à la police de
démêler le vrai du faux bien entendu
mais quelle serait le but de
déstabiliser qu'une jeune femme comme ça
de 22 ans enfin ce serait quoi son but
en fait ça je comprends pas ce que dit
l'entourage de Sébastien C c'est que
c'est une tentative globale de
déstabilisation de lui qui sort en ce
moment et cetera voilà moi je ne fais
que relaté ce que eux estiment he
machination dabilisation je suis comme
toi je comprends pas Miriam je suis
comme toi parce qu'on la voit ils ont
les registres des des des des invités à
nnergie parce qu'il fait son émission en
public elle vient souvent à l'émission
en public elle est dans le public elle
elle rigole elle a elle a l'air contente
il ils sont en train de de voir s'ils
ont les les vidéos qui parce que c'est
filmé aussi la radio donc j'arrive pas à
comprendre que se fait violer deux fois
en 10 ans en 10 ans d'écart elle
continue à aller le voir elle continue
alors on me dit syndrome de Stockholm
l'emprise commeation l'pris tuas le déis
tu as plein de choses dans les affaires
de viol je suis d'accord je suis
d'accord moi je je bon je suis un je
suis un con un con je n'arrive pas à me
dire qu'on va venir on va venir on va
venir je n'arrive pas à me dire moi avec
ma tête de con qu'on va venir 10 fois
une émission 5 fois une émission qu'on
va suivre la personne dans le sud de la
France qu'on va aller réclamer tout le
temps après cette personne qui t'a violé
deux fois en 10 an alors faut qu' aille
au bout moi je veux qu'elle aille au
bout je veux vraiment la vérité moi
c'est là-dessus moi surtout là là-dessus
je veux je veux vraiment qu'elle pousse
le
truc et je veux je veux qu'elle soit
déterminée cette femme je veux pas
qu'elle lâche l'affaire parce que moi ce
qu'on me dit et ce qu'on me rapporte bah
c'est c'est c'est des inscriptions à des
émissions sur énergie c'est ça lui court
après quand il quand il va mixer en
boîte de nuit elle essaie aussi d'aller
le rencontrer quand il mixe en boîte de
nuit c'est un peu chiant je veux qu'elle
aille au bout cette femme et qui donne
toutes ses éléments c'est parce que
c'est et encore une fois sur les
messages qui ont été supprimés pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils sont extrêmement
importants puisque ces messages
potentiels posent la question du
consentement et c'est pas du tout la M
éventuelle peine si cette jeune femme
était consentante c'est s'il y avait une
réponse dans son sens ça aurait voulu
dire que cette femme était consentante
là c'est présenté d'une telle manière
que cé écrit tout seul tient des propos
sexuels seul et qu'elle elle répond
seulement par bonjour oui ça va
attention en France le constantement
pour un viol n'existe pour un viol dans
éch dans les échanges dans les échanges
textau qu'ils ont eu si elle a répondu
d'une manière positive de manière à ce
que cé continue la conversation ce
serait une preuve de cons M
chou dire non je disais si j'écouterai
mon c'est que tout porte à croire
qu'elle était fan même une fois quecnu
qu'elle continueer à l'émission qu'elle
continue à l'admirer et cetera donc si
on parle de ce principe là pourquoi elle
voudrait le déstabiliseris rien c'est
pour ça qu'il faut unequte
de justement tu as raison c'est pour ça
qu'il faut une enquête de police c'est
pour ça qu' il faut qu'elle aille au
bout qu'elle ne s'arrête pas en de
chemin qu' fon qu'elle clarifie tout
noir sur blanc et qu' disent ok j' à ses
émissions ok je lui ai couru après mais
regardez ce qu'il a fait c'est c'est
c'est ça doit être puni par la loi et il
faut qu'elle aille au bout et Sébastien
cé il faut qu'il montre tout ce qu'il a
à montrer et c'est pour ça que l'enquête
elle est là je suis d'accord avec ce que
tu dis je dis pas le contraire je dis
juste que je veux que cette femme elle
aille au bout et Sébastien cé il va au
bout de ce qu'il a et au final au final
la police et l'enquête et la justice va
dire voilà toi tu as raison toi tu as
tort c'est pas c'est pas compliqué il
avait porté plainte pour harcèlement
cyber harcèlement en amont et là il
porte plainte voilà cyber harcèlement là
il plainte pour dénonciation calomnieuse
cyberhcèlement il porte plainte pour
dénonciation calomnieuse hein donc il
estime qu'il n'y a rien c'est-à-dire que
quand je disais dénigrement machination
calomnie voilà ça c'est de j'ai
l'impression que vous vous en voulez à
Sébastien C vous vous en voulez la terre
entière en fait non mais c'est vrai en
fait non mais c'est vrai non mais on VO
on sent on sent à chaque fois que vous
arrivez sur le plateau vous
êtes St Plaz onou pas des éléments pas
des éléments contraires
pas PL aussi tu étais
énervé pas du tout mais c'est pas du
tout pas
éner même pas elle énervée surt ltiaidée
elle est énervée elle est toujours
énervée non mais c'est vrai LTI qui pas
vendu sa maison elle est
énervée il paraî que la maison est
vendue d'ailleurs mais non j'ai un scoup
21h1 on me dit que la maison il vont
bien alors on me dit que la maison al je
vais me faire défoncer et le prix parce
que pris mais je vous dis apparemment la
maison est en train de se vendre mais
c'est incroyable ça j'ai j'ai je vous le
dis un gars alors apparemment c'est il
se serait mis
d'accord serait mis d'accord je vous dis
je vous laisse la on se retrouve
demain